throughout my career the vast majority
of particularly our most successful
investments have been ones that have
been controversial in one way or another
activism is a shareholder who behaves
like an owner people call these hostile
bids it's not hostile to the
shareholders in these companies it's
only hostile because it's not something
that management of the target company
has requested I think to decide to take
on a 33 year old pyramid scheme and call
a company a permit scheme publicly
there's some boldness associated with
that we shorted the credit of a triple-a
rated company MBIA because that's a bold
call calling a triple-a rated company
insolvent but we did it we bought the
stock of a company called General Growth
when it hit 34 cents down from $34 a
share people just don't make money or
hadn't until that point I made money
buying the stock of a bankrupt company
it's been a hundred and fifteen times a
profit multiple of the original
investment we like businesses that we
call them simple predictable free cash
flow generative dominant companies
businesses with a moat around them and
the way we make these decisions as we do
our analysis and then we look for a
company you can buy at a very deep
discount to what it's worth and if the
discount is a management issue a
strategy issue a cost structure issue a
hidden asset issue the problem that we
can solve and then we work to solve the
problem
[Music]
Richard rainwater is one of the great
investors of all time came to speak at
Harvard Business School when I was a
student I was thinking about starting my
own investment firm I said I asked
Richard what he thought the idea he said
you know Bill you don't need to be old
to be right that was enough for me and I
started an investment fund I graduated
at 26 what we do for a living I think
buying steaks and companies and working
to make them more valuable more
efficient more effective I think it's
great for the shareholders that gets
great the employees I think I can do
some good with that and then it's also
very profitable and I think that's oh I
like my day job